GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S GETTING A
SHOUT OUT TO MEXICO TONIGHT.
HE'S CREDITING OFFICIALS WITH
BREAKING UP A CARAVAN OF CENTRAL
AMERICANS AIMING TO CROSS INTO
THE U.S. AT THE MEXICAN BORDER.
THIS COMES AS THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN TO PUT NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS ON THE BORDER IS
SCRUTINIZED, BOTH TECHNICALLY
AND POLITICALLY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU, BRET.
PLENTY OF CRITICISM FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S PLAN TO PUT
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ON THE
BORDER.
PEOPLE THINKING IT'S A NECESSARY
AND WAY TOO EXPENSIVE.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO PLENTY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE APPLAUDING THE
PRESIDENT'S DECISION.
>> AND WEST VIRGINIA TO PROMOTE
HIS TAX CUT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TURNED HIS EYES SOUTHWARD,
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTT
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTE
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTN
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTT
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTO
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTA
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUT
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTU
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTR
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTD
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTT
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTO
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTS
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTC
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTR
EXPLAINING WHY HE'S CALLING OUTE
THE BORDER.
>> WE ARE WORKING OUT SYSTEMS
NOW AND WE CALLED OUT THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
WE ARE DOING A REAL JOB.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THE LAWS OF
THIS COUNTRY HAVE TO BE
STRENGTHENED AND TOUGHENED UP.
>> CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
IS WORKING UP RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE FOR A
TRIP TO PARLIAMENT.
THE DOD WILL APPROACH GOVERNORS
FROM FOUR BORN THE MIKE BORDER
STATES TO SEE IF THEY CAN
FULFILL THE MISSION WITH THEIR
OWN TROOPS.
IF NOT, THE PENTAGON WILL LIKELY
APPROACH OTHER STATES TO FILL IN
THE BLANKS.
TEXAS, NEW MEXICO, ARIZONA
WELCOMED THE IDEA.
UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT IS WHETHER
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
WILL AGREE TO SEND HIS DATES
TRIP TO THE BORDER.
CERTAINLY, HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON IMMIGRATION
IS TROUBLE.
>> GOVERNOR BROWN HAS DONE A
VERY POOR JOB EARNING
CALIFORNIA.
>> DHS SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN SAYS TALKS WITH BROWN
CONTINUE.
>> HE HAS SEEN THIS HAPPEN
BEFORE.
HE HAS SEEN IT HAPPEN WELL.
THE BORDER PATROL CAN DO BORDER
PATROL WORK.
I AM HOPEFUL, I WILL CONTINUE TO
TALK TO HIM AND SEE WHAT WE CAN
WORK OUT.
>> WHAT BRING THIS ISSUES TO THE
FORT MIKE FOREFRONT WAS REPORTS
OF A CARAVAN OF MORE THAN 1,000
CENTRAL AMERICAN MIGRANTS HEADED
FOR THE U.S. BORDER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY PRAISED
MEXICO FOR AS HE CLAIMED
BREAKING OF THE CARAVAN.
THE NUMBERS WERE OVERINFLATED.
>> MEXICO HAS BEEN PRETTY GOOD.
THEY WERE VERY GOOD TO US
YESTERDAY BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE A CARAVAN OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE COMING UP FROM
HONDURAS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
AND WE HAVE VERY WEAK LAWS
BECAUSE OF THE DEMOCRATS.
>> IT WAS THE PRESIDENT'S FOURTH
VISIT TO WEST VIRGINIA, A STATE
HE WON MIKE BY NEARLY 40 POINTS
AND A PROMISE TO BRING BACK
JOBS.
HE FOUND A FRIENDLY AUDIENCE FOR
HIS TOUGH STANCE AGAINST CHINA
AND HAS PROPOSED TARIFFS ON
$60 BILLION WORTH OF CHINESE
GOODS.
>> YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER THE
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T TREATING YOU
RIGHT.
IT HAD MANY RESPECTS, I THINK WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE A FANTASTIC
RELATIONSHIP COME A LONG TERM
WITH CHINA.
BUT WE HAVE TO GET THAT
STRAIGHTENED OUT, WE HAVE TO
HAVE SOME BALANCE.
>> MANY INDUSTRIES ARE
HYPERVENTILATING AT THE PROSPECT
OF RETALIATORY TARIFFS ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY BY CHINA AGAINST U.S.
GOODS AND WHETHER IT COULD SET
OFF A DEBILITATING TRADE WAR.
SO THE U.S. AGAIN TODAY
DISPATCHED THE U.S. CHIEF
ECONOMIC ADVISOR TO TELL
AMERICAN PRODUCERS TO JUST
EXHALE.
>> BOTH COUNTRIES HAVE JUST
PROPOSED TARIFFS WITH NOTHING
ENACTED.
LET'S NOT JUMP TO WORST-CASE
SCENARIO.
THE INTENT OF THE PRESIDENT IS
TO GROW THE AMERICAN ECONOMY,
NOT HURT IT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS USING THE
ECONOMIC ARGUMENT AGAINST
WEST VIRGINIA AND SENATOR JOE
MANCHIN COME UP FOR ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER.
THE PRESIDENT TODAY BLAMING HIM
FOR EVERYTHING BUT THE WEATHER.
>> JOE, YOU VOTED AGAINST -- IT
WAS BAD.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
BUT HE VOTES AGAINST EVERYTHING
AND HE VOTED AGAINST TAX CUTS.
HE ALSO VOTED AGAINST MEDICAL
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE.
AND HE DOES OTHER THINGS THAT I
DON'T LIKE, I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
>> THE PLAN FOR DEPLOYING TROOPS
TO THE BORDER IS STILL BEING
FINALIZED, PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
AIR FORCE ONE ON THE WAY BACK
FROM WEST VIRGINIA THIS
AFTERNOON SAID HE WOULD LIKE TO
PUT BETWEEN TWO AND 4,000 TROOPS
ON THE BORDER AND HE WOULD LIKE